in uganda schools are opening again for
the first time since march 2020 when
rising cases of covet 19 caused the
government to impose some of africa's
toughest restrictions but many students
say they've lost faith in education and
won't be returning uganda's government
and global experts warn a whole
generation could be about to lose out on
their opportunity for education
repairing motorcycles this is amir
kakanda's daily life now he was 14 when
his school closed due to the pandemic
after nearly two years they're finally
opening again but he's not going back
we are now starting to lose power
because everything we have seen
schooling is just sloping down
everything is going stagnant and we need
to
to look for a better way to live
kokonda's father left now at 16 he has
to take care of his two brothers alone
i had a idea that everything it can be
easy
when you have your books here
when you be with that education thingy
but not even life can be there without
having books
kokonda had already picked up his school
supplies in preparation for his return
but now he won't need them the
government estimates a good 30 percent
of ugandan students won't come back to
the classroom
this elementary school fears that number
could be much higher teachers prepared
together to start school creating class
books
children or five years
moving around selling those cheap things
eggs
bananas for me i call this one as
a lost generation
an existing learning crisis has gotten
worse according to the united nations
children's fund up to 70 percent of 10
year olds in low and middle income
countries can't read nearly 20 percent
more than before corona
if you've dropped out of school and not
returning that will have a lifelong
implications for you globally it's
estimated trillions of dollar impact uh
on economies globally due as a result of
the learning laws through the pandemic
many experts say more support for global
education is needed to help young
generations break free from cycles of
poverty
you